hey leute und verkauf seiner neuen mod
review heute stelle ich euch den motto
caustic mod vor ihr kennt mit sicherheit
alle den pogo stick von spielen wie
happy meals oder so wo man dann einfach
auf einem also nicht auf einen er also
nicht auf einem schatz den man einfach
auf einem stift quasi auf dem stift
drauf sitzt und man hüpft dann immer so
rum durch die gegend durch die
landschaft usw
solltet ihr eigentlich kennen und da
habe ich nun einen mord gefunden der das
ganze auch in eurem minecraft welt
hinein fügt ich zeige euch erst mal ganz
kurz wie man das kraft und zwar macht
ihr hier wie einen eimer so aus iron
ingots dann dazwischen einen stick unten
links unten rechts ein slime ball und in
die mitte von den beiden ein ob sie
ihren blog dann bekommt ihr den pogo
stick den fokus tick könnt ihr einfach
also anwählen ganz normal die hatten
richtig richtig tolles design muss ich
sagen erinnert mich so ein bisschen an
so ein kloß stift den man ihnen
irgendwie ins klo tut damit man
irgendwie restaurants und aber dass ein
anderes thema mit rechtsklick platziert
er den einfach und wenn ihr wieder
abbauen wollt klickt ihr einfach die
ganze zeit mit linksklick da drauf und
irgendwann verschwindet er dann da ich
im creative mode bin habe ich jetzt
gerade zwei von daher lasst euch nicht
von dem hier irritieren ihre tiere dir
also rechtsklick dann wieder rechts sich
darauf dann seid ihr darauf dann könnt
ihr schon den ganzen zeitraum hüpfen ich
drücke gerade gar nichts also der hüpft
immer die ganze zeit von alleine so
sieht das aus wenn ihr danach draufsteht
ist halt na ja wenn ich jetzt so stehe
hat er das mit einer hand und sodann
wieder mit gar keiner hand also es ist
ganz interessant an dem design muss noch
ein bisschen bearbeitet werden aber ich
finde dass es mal so ganz cool ich
könnte jetzt mal ein bisschen so
geradeaus hüpfe ich drück hat wirklich
einfach nur noch geradeaus und der
beschleunigt danach derzeit auch also
dass man nach der zeit wirklich immer
weiter springt hier habe ich schon so
eine kleine fläche was ein bisschen
ausgehoben damit dem man sieht wie
schnell man damit auch sein kann weil
wir nicht zum beispiel wieder ganz
normal köpfe und jetzt wieder nach vorne
dann geht das erst langsam und jetzt
geht es wirklich immer schneller
also das ist echt eigentlich ganz cool
also wenn man ihn wie schnell vor in
welchen leuten davon sei gehen will ich
weiß nicht ob das auch für server gibt
aber auf jeden fall im singleplayer ganz
cool wenn ihr in eurer eigenen let's
play welt irgendwie sowas machen wollte
und schaut mal
wenn man damit auf irgendwelche mops
drauf springt auf zombies oder auf
schweine oder auf kühe auf irgendwas auf
scharfe di santo moment die sind fast
immer direkt tot also man muss die halt
schon richtig treffen
ich gehe hier mal kurz von runter du
bleibst da mal stehen habe ich dich
super gepackt und zwar habe ich mir das
ein kleines minispiel ausgedacht
beziehungsweise gefunden und zwar
spontan einfach ganz ganz viele schweine
so das ist natürlich erstmal jetzt ein
nervtötendes geräusch für euch zuschauer
gerade schnappt euch auch im fokus tick
springt hoch und versucht so viele
schweine wie möglich in einem dingen zu
töten in einem jump 1 also zu treffen
das war zum beispiel fünf jetzt könnte
wieder von vorne anfangen
ihr wisst wie ich das ungefähr meinen
also hier installiert den hot ganz
einfach weil ich da echt mal viele leute
fragen wie man denn teilweise mods
installiert die installiert das komplett
installiert den hot indem ihr einfach
euch das forum unter ladet ihr findet
den link in der beschreibung und zieht
einfach die datei die er dann habt in
den mods ordner in eurer minecraft datei
denkens und vorher müsste auch nach dem
motto oder installieren also das ist
eigentlich ganz einfach erklärt einfach
auf der website bisschen augen auf sein
auge auf leighton machen eure kleinen
einfach aufmachen bisschen rum schauen
bis zum schnüffeln findet ihr schon raus
wie man das richtig installiert ist
eigentlich ganz einfach der mut macht
extrem viel spaß ich geb dem motto ich
mach das mal so dass sich die mods jetzt
bewährte von zehn diamanten gebe ich dem
motto ich sag mal acht weil er wirklich
noch ein bisschen ausbaufähig ist und ja
dann würde ich sagen sehen wir zum
nächsten video leute ich würde mich aber
daumen hoch freuen wir sind zunächst mal
tschüss